know this from Vox scientists warned we
may need to live with social distancing
for a year or more a bigger or more a
year you mean I can't go see any movies
I don't buy it listen man I totally get
there like three months thing that makes
sense to me yeah but if they're if
they're starting to push for these
extreme authoritarian positions yeah
they're like it's it's starting to get
me really really angry yeah because I
think they're trying to exploit all of
this yep you see there was a guy on
Twitter he's a saint apparently he works
with the USDA okay oh my god you saw
that tweet yeah where he was like curfew
is coming and we may have to start
rationing your food so you better not
snap at me cuz guess which division is
gonna be doing it and the guy responded
like are you implying that you're gonna
restrict emergency supplies to me for
like snarking at you on Twitter and the
guys are I'm just saying it's really
dumb you know it's really dumb is saying
that holy cow I don't know man what made
it so so at what point is it reasonable
to be alike let's GTFO yeah stores Sam
where are you gonna go away from the
urban center where people are now free
to like do we live in Philly we live in
the Philly suburbs man we are ten
minutes away from Philadelphia it's like
literally like hop in the car on the
bridge and boom were there stop Jersey
but we're not yeah I know so I'm happy
yeah I'm happy about that for a while is
actually like I probably should have
moved to the Philly area like the second
that's why now it's like crime is legal
feels like it feels like they're just
they're just trying to avoid it well
well actually I'm trying to stay safe
and stay healthy
my friends over in the filly side Philly
Philly side said that there was a large
blaring siren that said for the next 24
hours all crime is legal Joker joke the
verge is real I tried what but for real
real question if if they're saying
they're not gonna arrest people for
burglary mm-hmm that means like you
could be living in Philly someone could
kick your door and
a gun yeah you sorry thing cops aren't
gonna come they don't shoot you they're
good well isn't that violent no burglary
with a gun kicking your door down
apparently dude they're saying they
could steal from you personally and it's
they're not gonna arrest you for it
that's why I'm saying they're
straight-up saying we're not gonna dude
someone could okay someone could calmly
open your door and then start taking
stuff from you and you could call the
police say a strange man has entered my
home and stealing my stuff and they're
gonna be like and you don't come I'm
gonna I'm gonna kill him I'm not leaving
I feel threatened I think they might
resume Erica
I think they'll still respond yeah
they're gonna they're they're not saying
they're not responding to any okay so
hold on hold on so what happens now when
they show up in the guys in the house
they take him outside what's your name
sir well they I'm sure they're gonna
remove him from the house yeah yeah well
and what's your name sir you know I'm
bill okay bill what's your last name
Smith and where do you live one two
three fixture okay we'll be one two
three fake street yeah we'll be back in
90 days to arrest you oh my god so
anyway yeah and that's it there go home
and then the cops are gonna leave and
he's gonna walk cross street go in the
next house and rob somebody
dude look the point is if someone could
smash the window of your car and steal
your car and you call them about what
we're not gonna arrest the guy well the
thing too is that if the cops show up at
all people are gonna be calling them all
the time they are gonna be massively
overloaded because people are gonna be
like oh my gosh this is Christmas early
well apparently people have been calling
911 because I ran out of toilet paper
yeah not even kidding no that's
ridiculous
people have been calling 9-1-1 because
people are cutting them in line at the
supermarket they're like fighting over
stuff the ridiculous how much longer
like how much strain can assist him bear
like it was a it was it was like one day
all of a sudden everything went boom and
it just went nuts the system was already
strained yeah that's the thing it's like
we were already that tension was already
you know was there up to it exactly has
been talking about some kind of war for
a really long time I don't know no that
sounds like a [ __ ] do you think you
possibly think there'd be a civil war I
think they made a mistake by even
announcing yes they should have kept
this on the down-low right like what
what what without reason though what
we're announcing what the arrests the
fact that
not all arrests they're trying to detain
these nonviolent crimes it feels like
they're going like go ahead and do it
exactly go do it by the way we're gonna
just detain you we're not gonna arrest
you I got Taisha cago story going on we
tie you Chicago story so this is like 13
14 years ago or actually meant maybe
like 15 or 16 so there was a fentanyl
so I becoming this big thing right
mm-hmm super heroin they were calling it
and local Fox 32 no no no no I'm sorry I
don't know if it was them so I'm gonna
I'm gonna take the back sorry Fox
straight I'm not around I'm not trying
to rag on you guys a local knows I like
it I don't know which one I made but all
of them I don't know okay reported that
super heroin and made its way to Chicago
super heroin and guess what they said in
their story oh yeah several people have
overdosed on what's being called super
heroin that they were poorly obtained at
63rd and Cicero in the Chicago's South
Side and then what happened the next day
16 dead at 63rd and Cicero because they
watched the news learned where to go
pick it up showed up got it and then
died Wow yep exactly I guess oh yeah I
remember saying the news and being like
why are they telling us where they
picked the drugs someone someone in the
comments wrote some hilarious they go
just right on the front door like we
have coronavirus because because then
you're gonna get these like crazy
looking dudes in like old testement
hazmat suits kicking the door with like
a harpoon gun and they're gonna call the
cops and the cops are gonna show up to
the door and be like oh we can't help
you you're on your own mayor on your own
you're on your own dude what if we go
full fallout yeah it's not gonna go
there
no no but but but hold on man optimism
bias bro did you think we were gonna be
I did no curfew here kind of no you know
I'm doing it as soon as we finish this
podcast home as a pandemic a long time
ago I was like this is a pandemic it's
too when I were talking we need to get
prepared we need to get supplies
everyone else should be prepared for
whatever happens yeah and look where we
are
we're sorry people know I'm not
surprised you know what I'm gonna do
once we finish this hmm I'm gonna run
out to the Front Street
and I'm gonna sergeant that Joker dance
because ain't nobody gonna stop me
well that's a non-violent crime that's
right it is yeah we're not in Phil oh
it's not a crime though going out after
eight billing and it was suggested 19
right it's a strong well so here's what
here's what the way they worded it they
said the report I saw said residents of
New Jersey are not to leave their homes
between the hours of 8:00 p.m. and 5:00
a.m. in a dress you know in one of the
most drastic efforts to stem the
coronavirus the governor Phil Murphy has
recommended and I was like well await
but has recommended and they shrink the
text a little bit so it's a little
smaller
no no but here's what happens other
outlets pick the story up and remove the
last bit yeah and sent residents did
stay in between 8:00 and 5:00 p.m.
according to governor mm-hmm yeah
correct and then all of a sudden people
started reporting I saw CNN say it they
left out the part where he was saying
I'm suggesting I'm discouraging so here
we are no no no but I think it's a legit
question think about it Philly just said
we're not gonna arrest people who steal
your car and burglarize your home I mean
that's drastic I mean is this is this
the city of Philadelphia yes okay so
it's the city well let's look it says
Philadelphia police yeah yeah so think
about that think about the fact the
stores are empty people just went out
and bought all the guns yeah at what and
all the food dude hey we are sitting on
a food is being bought out so so think
about this way so all the ingredients
are there for calamity yeah man there's
no there's no enforcement
there's no National Guard deployment
people got guns they're panicked
stockpiling food and you know some
people didn't get any exactly we don't
have milk I don't care that we don't
have milk that's the no no that's the
top of your one of the top things listen
we know no notes I'm not swimming
through the cracks that we ran out right
and we went out you know a month ago and
got dry foods right and went out again
and now today we can't so think about
the people who didn't go out at all
yeah yeah and so now they're sitting
there like there's no food to store I
mean there's constant tweets even
friends of mine are going
I haven't stocked up on or the toilet
paper no I have to use your hand in
Washington about two other bit but
they're just like well now I can't find
it anywhere I had to drive 40 miles to
get like wow
so I feel like we are sitting on a
powder keg waiting for that match spark
that's how close it feels you know it is
you've got a government you suggested
curfew government mandated closure of
all private businesses yeah that's all
looks like dude we are getting a lot in
that the crazy thing is a lot of these
small businesses cannot afford this
they're gonna go out yep
they were talking about all the time
over the past few years that the average
American can't afford a $400 swing yeah
in an emergency situation whatever now
they're not even able to work yep
so they're not getting money and this is
this is pretty pretty bad like a lot of
people are gonna be out of money
unemployment unemployment right right
tell me about the it was like in Ohio it
went from 6500 claims to 45,000 dude
people are getting straight-up fired
yeah do you want something scary it
wasn't it st. when st. Patty's Day was
that today was it today so right now
yeah it's today
there you go I'm wearing somebody I saw
I saw a message on oh yeah I'm wearing
like I saw a message where someone said
because we didn't know what was gonna
happen
mm-hmm because we've been given no
guidance from the government yeah we had
no choice but to preorder the food we
need for a normal st. Patty's Day which
is which is bonkers which is tons of
wings and beers and then the last minute
the government says we're shutting you
down and now they said all of this food
is gonna spoil we spent 20 grand on food
we're gonna make no money we're laying
off our staff yeah businesses are
closing small businesses are all like
this that they've been struggling for
years you know Amazon Walmart all these
huge companies that are taken over now
this comes and shuts it all down the
government shuts them down and then
they're like what are they gonna be able
to do they can't afford in two months to
reopen and buy all new stuff yep it's
like that alone is incredibly expensive
just buying new food just start again
it's well we should we've actually got
another story about all that stuff so I
think we'll save a little bit sure sure
that the spike on a plane we'll get to
that stuff too yeah but I think for now
I'll just we'll wrap up this first
portion jump
I'm just thinking man amazing a amazing
atheist gonna cite him again
at what point do you panic yeah they
keep saying now is not the time we had a
market crash food shortage let me stop
you right there amazing atheist cuz you
mentioned the stock market crash and a
foo and and a pandemic let me add
something to that food shortage and
people mass buying guns and now they're
not gonna arrest people so at what point
do you think people are gonna start
freaking out right this would be the
point I mean I'll tell you what right
now you're watching no we're not that is
meant so I'm like I'm clearly not
freaking out what I'll be I'll be on
there yeah a little bit what other
criteria should be met for us to freak
out do you think oh man I I feel like
I'm freaked out you know well I mean I'm
not gonna run around with my hair on
fire or anything but like what what
would be like if I start seeing roving
bands of like you know Bandidos yeah
with like I don't know weapons and clubs
and they're like reigning stores
something I'm getting out like if I see
some looting or something that's what
I'm gonna be like okay because what can
we do we're in a suburban house
surrounded
I mean if Philly is not gonna enforce
certain things so if we get to that
point that's that's it for me like when
people so here's what I'm worried about
I want to know the difference like what
is their procedures because they're not
even telling us they're the same
normally be arrested there would just be
temporarily detained to take your
information firm identification and
complete the necessary paperwork they do
this already so it so there's there an
Illinois called an AI bond where a cop
can walk up to you and say you serve
been arrested for this here's an AI bond
we'll see you in court
and you they've literally claimed like
you've been arrested released in charged
on the spot so we're detaining means
they're gonna why wouldn't they
institute that instead because they're
they don't want to gum up paperwork I
guess I have no idea that it says that
they're gonna do the necessary paperwork
you're right it doesn't literally says
it right so all I see is they don't want
to touch people yeah I'm dead serious
they don't want to get any of their
police force in fact that's that's what
the that's kind of fair so I guess I
guess the last thing I can say right now
is a it's the end of the world as we
know it
I feel fine do you feel fine it is a
good song it's a great song yeah it's
all it's all coming up I thought I would
be you know I thought when when we got
to this point let's let's let's break it
down one more time we got you know
government curfew not not mandated but
we've got government mandated closure of
all businesses police in Philly not
making arrests food shortages people are
mass buying ammo global pandemic I kind
of felt like you know when I would think
about something like this maybe a year
ago I thought it would feel different
I'm kind of bored you know just sitting
around it's like I wake up I go to work
I work from home so I'm like I'm gonna
get back to reading the news I was that
coronavirus again oh look at that yeah I
was talking to my buddy earlier when we
were we were gaming and he's like yep
gamers are gonna be fine
yeah I'm like yeah we're saying Iraq
it's like what do we do anyway and we
self isolate and social distance because
we got the internet it's not I don't
feel like I have social distance things
cuz I'm he's in my headphones were
chatting we're laughing we're playing
our games you know it's like smart we'll
be good smart yeah until the food runs
out that's your point right now though
the Cheetos run out you know our vitamin
C comes from China were you saying that
before all of our medicines come from
but no like vitamin C so dude are you
kidding man they got citrus I try to
manage citrus in like a mine and where
you're gonna get oranges you're gonna
have to like eat rabbit liver or
something I think there's vitamin C and
livers I think I'm good I was REME sure
you can find it in vegetables I'm sure
there's well yeah but do you know do you
like grass
yes that's my plan tree thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you